was geht hier ist ein max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video heute eine
freude machen wir mal wieder etwas mit
knete und zwar hat die mit ein paar
vorschläge geben was ich bauen soll und
die alte post in sachen die hier im
video kneten soll herr staeck kneten mal
markt und das wird jetzt gemacht ich
suche mir fünf sachen raus ich habe dann
jeweils eine halbe minute zeit das zu
bauen und dann gucken ist das endprodukt
so leute es geht los
als erstes soll ich die roten sneaker
von apa red
[Musik]
zwei leute dass das endprodukt rote
sneak er ist eigentlich plural aber 30
sekunden sind verdammt wenig zeit ich
finde also es ist nicht so kaffee oder
[Musik]
also man sieht hier eindeutig die
schnürsenkel dich gar nicht mehr in der
offiziellen zeit gemacht habe aber hier
sieht schon aus dem schuh finde ich ist
das hier im wert von einem tierpark
ich weiß ja nicht recht leute nicht so
recht leite ich weiß eigentlich recht
leute scheinen die kommentare ist das im
wert von und tierpark nummer eins ist
abgehakt nummer zwei ist einen kran soll
ich bauen und ich würde sagen wir machen
es einfach wieder 30 sekunden ist so
schwierig da irgendwas hinzukriegen kann
es auch selbst mal ausprobieren aber
okay
[Musik]
haha leute es nicht dass das alle größte
was man nur schafft in dieser zeit aber
runter gefallen das ist ein kranich
finden kannst naja man kann es nicht so
wirklich erkennen oder ok aber natürlich
finde ich schon ziemlich scheiße ist
oder so
[Musik]
die express keine kaufempfehlung leute
nummer drei wird gebaut ich soll einen
youtube play button bauen youtube play
warten wäre außenspiegel mit verkehrten
farben beiden ist eigentlich das play
zeichen in diese richtung g 30 sekunden
sind echt wenig zeit von dingen habe ich
noch andere vorschläge kommt die ich
auch machen werde die eigentlich viel
mehr zeit brauchen egal aber dass die
challenge ja es ist die 30 sekunden
knicks challenge so leute nächster
vorschlag ist penis wertes erwartet
[Musik]
leute wie fertig mein name ist was mache
ich eigentlich für sachen auf mein
youtube kanals unglaublich ja also schon
relativ simpel ist nicht besonders
detailliert ich habe probiert hier vorne
so ein bisschen shape zu geben aber ich
glaube ein zweites beispiel das dann
kritisch gewesen im hinblick auf youtube
nutzung nummer vier
wo es fängt an zu regnen am anfang von
video was du mir das hier und jetzt der
letzte vorschlag richtig schwierig da
die und ihren verlobten einen audi heißt
bei der hochzeit gott leute dafür einen
youtube will ich sagen ja also ein
bisschen mehr zeit muss auf jeden fall
sein es wird trotzdem richtig knapp
[Musik]
sehr gut zu erkennen sind hier
man kennt hier erkennt ihr dabei
charakteristisch für sie keine füße
keine hände ein kreis als körper und der
kopf ist ein bisschen deplatziert also
das finde ich
zehn von zehn wo dann die hochzeit hier
äußerst kreativ durch einen altar
dargestellt als erkennt man auch top und
zu guter letzt folgen hier
man sieht hier das gibt das binger hafte
aussehen die berner hafte attitüde die
eine oder andere verletzung wie man als
banker sich zuzieht ist auch gegeben zum
beispiel der abend ein bisschen kürzer
als der andere bei uns mal den direkten
vergleich macht und ja ich würde sagen
ich habe diese challenge neussers
googles abgeschlossen jetzt gefallen ist
war richtig schlecht